[Music]
good morning and thank you so much for
joining us today so the digital and tech
giants began with cute logos and hips
slogans but they're rapidly morphing
into a 21st century vision version of
Fritz Lang's Metropolis growing into the
largest corporations the world has ever
seen
Apple alone is worth more than the GDP
of 90% of the countries in the world
many now see these companies as
malevolent monopolies with massive
largely untaxed profits manipulate our
behavior for their own benefit some even
claim that the epidemic of mental
ill-health can be laid at their door if
we want to escape their vision of the
future can they be stopped does their
power and influence signal the loss of
control of national governments two
global corporations or is it still
possible for governments to fight back
and if so how with me to discuss this is
this wonderful panel that we have to my
far left we have Shoshana Zubov author
of the incredible book surveillance
capitalism about which more later and in
the bookshop we have bin affan ah me who
is a member of parliament we have the
author Johanna Cavanaugh whose
outstanding novel Zed I cannot recommend
enough I laughed and was horrified the
entire way through and finally last but
not least at all Angela eagle to my
right who's also a member of parliament
so the first part is what should worry
us most about the digital and tech
giant's vision of the future Shoshanna
you've literally written the book so
we'll start with you I would like to
turn this question to you in a in a
certain way what are the concerns what
are the feelings what are the issues
that brought you here this morning
instead of going to Brighton
and if you could just think about that
for a moment and shout out one word that
represents why you're here what is the
key concern love to hear that
and then I'll make a very quick response
and we'll stay within the three minutes
tell me what manipulation transparency
climate emergency
what was that democracy thank you okay
so I didn't bring this folder with me
but here's the thing my book this book
was published in January and as you can
imagine I've been going around to a lot
of countries and cities they're talking
to wonderful groups of people like you
and I asked this question everywhere I
go and here's what's happening every
group of people that I visit with are
producing the same lists of words
autonomy manipulation fear anxiety
democracy resistance literally
everything that you said today I've
heard all around the world this is why I
think it's so important what do they
call us well done you get the gold star
they call us users an anonymous unwashed
undifferentiated global population of
users but what your concerns reveal is
that we are beginning to not only feel
but articulate our shared social
political economic and indeed
psychological interest
we are no longer merely users we are
starting to get the fact that we are
actually used and beginning to think
about what's wrong with that and that is
going to lead to the sea change in
public opinion that will change our
politics and will change our future
that's where I'm coming from that's what
I'm devoted to and that's why I'm here
today and not at the beach thank you
thank you so much every to them over to
you what should worry us most about the
digital and tech giant's vision of the
future well thank you very much for for
being here so my sense of this is to
some degree similar but but slightly
different
what should worry us most is that they
have an entirely global reach a global
understanding a mass view of how they
treat every single one of us users but
we do not have not just us in the United
Kingdom but in different countries in
the world we do not have any sort of
governance mechanism that matches that
so there is a complete mismatch between
the ability of global tech giants to
operate which is on a global basis and
our ability to influence that which is
because we all operate in increasingly
national spheres and I mean increasingly
national because it is obvious to most
people that the world is going through
what you might see a sort of decoupling
from globalization in political terms
Adi a retrenchment
in most countries in the West and the
United
States being one very good example of
that and the United Kingdom with Briggs
it being another one and what that means
is we increasingly lack the ability to
govern these global actors who are
themselves through the use of technology
processing data as you were talking
about they are increasingly able to
operate globally and yet we are
decreasing ly able to influence that and
that is where the fear the anxiety comes
from because people can sense people can
smell that lack of agency and when they
say to their representatives whether
they be local MPs all the way up to the
prime minister or the government they
also know that these people can't do
anything about it either and that I
think is the core of our problem that we
should explore Thank You Joanna so yes I
really agree with what I've heard the
surveillance is huge we should be
terrified
shoshanna's Grix hugely important we're
forced as Edward Snowden said to live
naked before power and there's also a
crisis of democracy that comes from that
which is that as he's also pointed out
if you force a population to whom
surveillance is anathema to live under
surveillance you destroy democracy
you're forcing everyone to do something
they hate and you fracture your society
and I think also something that's a kind
of part of this and also goes beyond
this there's a massive change that's
occurred in 20 years almost everyone in
this room if you're over 20 you've lived
through a revolution the digital era and
that changes the whole dimension of
information and power it's a complete
transformation there's a weird interview
I don't know if any of you saw it 1999
David Bowie is interviewed by Jeremy
Paxman odd idea you may remember and
he's trying to tell Paxman about the
revolutionary import of the Internet and
at one point he says it's an alien
life-form Jeremy Paxman raises a
quizzical eyebrow but what he meant was
it completely adjust society and he says
it's going to cause us a disruption and
he talks about it's the realization of
dushawn
image of the art the artwork and the
audience that it used to be you had the
great artists the authority - claiming
to the audience and the audience is
silent and that's the transaction it's
on broadcast mode now the meaning of the
work is in the interaction between the
audience and the work of arts there's a
whole gray area and the tech companies
and the government's are still in this
kind of industrial mode where you
broadcast you lie you propagandize you
control that's the total disconnect
that's occurring and yet society has
fractured into all these communities
that talk amongst themselves that talk
back it's a complete transition and I
think that tension and the lack of a
vision instead really what happens is
more control you know more autocracy
more watching more surveillance that's
how the reaction seems to occur at the
moment and that has to change because
otherwise you fracture the whole thing
and you know the mirror has fractured
that used to reflect back that broadcast
mode and the pieces are there and you
can't you know keep talking in the same
way so I think that - and they will get
regulated in a way you know they should
be regulated they will be regulated but
that change is the massive massive
transformation I think
thanks very much rely first I'd like to
say that size does matter the five
largest tech companies are collectively
worth more than the entire economy in
the UK only four national economies are
larger than the combined tech giants and
that is the US China Japan and Germany
and I think unchecked these malevolent
monopolies are likely to grow even more
dominant and control more of our
existence our experience in our lives to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a I dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas